[موسيقى]
عندما أبدأ
كنت مستميتًا جدًا لأتذكر أنني كنت مجنونًا بذلك
لم أفكر في ذلك حتى
أهم شيء هذا الموسم وقوته
و بعد
أنا أتساءل ماذا أفعل لصنع تلك البطن.
[موسيقى]
ان
لاف واسمي غابة
الاحتلال هو مستعمرة وثنية مخطط جيدا
لقد كنت أقوم بهذا العمل لمدة 39 عامًا
يدور الضغط حول ضمان التكاثر
لأنها شركة ، أحصل على 50 سؤالاً من ملابس مختلفة وأصبغها.
أقوم أيضًا بصبغ مقالات مثل الجزء الخفي والبصر ، كما أنني أصبغ العديد من المقالات الأخرى.
يكون
[موسيقى]
لزج
همم
نعم
تكنولوجيا خاصة
لأن معظم الطرق الخالية من الهموم مصنوعة يدويًا.
سأقوم بعمل نمط يدويًا باستخدام مثل هذه الطريقة وهي سهلة.
ثم ادمجه مع الجذع المدفون
من الشائع وضع ما فعلته على لفافة حديدية وصبغها حارًا.
إنه تدفق
هناك طائرة والكثير من المظلات
يقال أنه يمكنك عمل نمط يبدو وكأنه تم استخدام لون مختلف
كان لديه هذه الوظيفة مع علامة تجارية مصممة أو شخص مشهور.
بعد كل شيء ، إذا أصبحت الأكثر شهرة ، فستكون Hermes.
[موسيقى]
لا شيء عن كيفية صنع مثل هؤلاء اليابانيين
أنا لم أكتب أي شيء في أي مكان
كل شيء في رأسي
كمشكلة مريحة ، من الصعب جدًا بالفعل الازدهار ، لكن هذا
لا توجد تكنولوجيا ، لذلك أريد أكبر عدد ممكن من الناس.
بالمناسبة ، سيد أوشينو ، السرطان قادم إلى منزلي الآن ، وأتذكر قولي هذا.
ولكن
جدا جدا
إنه ليس نمطًا يمكن القيام به ، لذلك إذا كان هناك أشخاص يمكنهم القيام بذلك ، فسيقوم أي شخص بالتدريس أو يظل الجزء المؤسف
كنت أفعل ذلك
[موسيقى]